How did Zeus come to rule a whole universe
of various divine pantheons?
How advanced has human technology become after
all these crises and infinity wars?
And where was Sif for the last 10 years?
These are the biggest unanswered questions
in "Thor: Love and Thunder."
Thor's iconic weapon Mjolnir has always been
something of a mystery.
Was it ever truly sentient?
How did it work, beyond the cop-out answer
of "magic?"
"Whosoever holds this hammer, if he be worthy,
shall possess the power of Thor."
How could it actually gauge a wielder's worthiness,
and does it psychically sense Thor's intentions
when thrown?
Similarly, everyone's favorite monosyllabic
tree person, Groot, has always been a bit
of an enigma.
How can he regrow from a single twig?
Does that mean that his consciousness is stored
in every little sliver of his wood?
If you cut him in half, do you end up with
two Groots?
What even is Groot?
"I am Groot!"
Right, well, that one might be answered already.
Regardless, the reason we bring up these two
mysteries together is that, as of "Infinity
War," the two sets of questions now all apply
to one item: Stormbreaker, the magic ax made
from the arm of Groot.
Stormbreaker has always been a bit of an unknown
in the MCU, given that it seems to have all
the powers of Mjolnir without the benefit
of any of Odin's spells.
And "Thor: Love and Thunder" ramps up the
weapon's power and mysterious nature tenfold.
In the movie, the weapon demonstrates obvious
sentience, and even a personality, by acting
petulant toward Thor when the God of Thunder
attempts to summon his old pal Mjolnir.
There may be an answer, one subtly revealed
early in the film: When Thor plants Stormbreaker
in the dirt, it grows roots.
Just like Groot was reborn from a tiny, burnt
little twig, it seems Stormbreaker may be
attempting to regrow itself from its handle
as well.
In the Marvel comics, the origin of All-Black
the Necrosword, the deadly weapon wielded
by Gorr the God Butcher, is thoroughly explained.
Over the course of multiple comic series,
the long history of the Necrosword, its true
nature as a living Symbiote, and its creator
— the dark god Knull — have been fully
fleshed out.
But throughout the weapon's MCU debut in "Thor:
Love and Thunder," the weapon is never explained
satisfactorily.
It is evident from the fact that every god
seems aware of and afraid of the Necrosword
that the weapon's history is long and storied,
but no portion of that story is ever revealed.
When we first see the sword, it lays motionless
next to the body of its former wielder, an
unnamed, dead god.
Beyond that, we never learn much about the
sword, aside from its habit of slowly poisoning
and maddening its wielder.
As of a post-credits scene in "Spider-Man:
No Way Home," at least, the Venom symbiote
does indeed exist in the MCU proper, so it's
possible that a more explicit connection to
symbiotes will be revealed in the future.
Okay, yes, the real-world answer to the question
of Sif's whereabouts since the events of "Thor:
The Dark World" has an easy enough answer:
The actor that portrays Sif, Jaime Alexander,
was busy filming her hit NBC crime-drama series
"Blindspot."
But every Hollywood production is limited
by availability, budget, and an endless amount
of other constraints, and those films, especially
if they're in a connected universe like the
MCU, need an in-canon explanation as well.
Lady Sif was absent from the big screen for
nine years, and according to "Thor: Love and
Thunder," the Asgardian warrior was... out
there.
Somewhere.
Fighting something.
For some reason.
When we catch up with Sif via an interstellar
distress signal in "Thor: Love and Thunder,"
she's in the midst of combat, fighting alongside
some unnamed alien gods against Gorr, and
losing badly.
However, that small bit of information is
where the statements end and the questions
begin.
Where was Sif all this time?
Was she not on Asgard when it fell?
If not, why?
Why didn't she return to New Asgard to help
her people rebuild their civilization?
Who were the gods she fought with, and how
did she know about Gorr well in advance of
Thor and the Guardians of the Galaxy?
In the MCU, for some reason, it seems that
Earth's gods are much more important to the
cosmos and its many goings-on than any other
planet's.
Just like Sif's absence, there is a simple
real-world explanation for this Earth bias:
The people who make and watch the movies are
all from Earth.
And while that certainly explains why we watch
movies about Thor instead of movies about
some random god from another random rock in
space, "Thor: Love and Thunder" added a couple
of remarkable details to the MCU that make
Earth's central status a bit more baffling.
Firstly, Omnipotence City, the meeting place
of all the universe's, or at least galaxy's,
many pantheons, is ruled over by Zeus, of
the Earth-based Greek pantheon.
Given that NASA estimates our galaxy to contain
over 100 billion planets, the odds that a
god from Earth would be in charge are, well,
about one in 100 billion.
Secondly, the film's second half centers around
Gorr's attempts to reach the abstract cosmic
entity known as Eternity, and for some reason,
the Bifrost is the one key to getting there.
For some reason, Earth's Norse Pantheon — and
specifically its God of Thunder — contains
the sole means of access to Eternity.
Surely one of the other 100 billion planets
has a more suitable pantheon and more suitable
god for getting to Eternity.
Earth's gods aren't the only beings whose
status in the cosmic order is in question
as of "Thor: Love and Thunder" — its regular
humans' status is, too.
When daily life in New Asgard is finally revealed
in greater detail, we see that it employs
its own police force, which is equipped with
armor and weapons that look purposefully half-human
and half-Asgardian.
That suggests an intermingling of technology,
just as their flying tour boats do.
Given the fact that at least some humans now
have access to Asgardian technology in this
story, and since the entire plot of "Black
Panther" revolves around the hyper-advanced
country finally sharing its technology with
the rest of the world as well, we can only
assume that the humans of the MCU are now
centuries more advanced than we are.
And there's another major asset that the MCU
humans have that we don't: Dr. Jane Foster.
When explaining her book and the research
behind it, Foster reveals that she has essentially
solved the physics behind Einstein-Rosen Bridges,
aka wormholes.
Given that many physicists believe that wormholes
are based on laws from both General Relativity
and Quantum Mechanics, Foster's findings heavily
imply that she has at least partially cracked
the Theory of Everything/Grand Unifying Theory.
Even being conservative, Foster's theoretical
advances, paired with newly-accessible Wakandan
and Asgardian tech, means that the humans
of Earth 616 have a bright future close at
hand.
In both the Marvel comics and the MCU, the
awesome, nigh-infinite power of Odin is named
the Odinforce.
It is one of the strongest and most versatile
energy sources in the universe, making Odin
more fearsome and formidable than nearly any
other god, and even as much as some cosmic
entities like Galactus.
The Odinforce is what allows Odin to empower
his spear Gungnir, the Destroyer, and even
Thor's trusty Mjolnir, so it is clearly a
force to be reckoned with.
That's why its absence from the MCU after
Odin's death is not only noticeable but raises
the question: Wait, where did it go?
In the comics, the Odinforce is passed down
from king to king — Bor wielded the Borforce
and then passed it to Odin as the Odinforce,
and he, in turn, passed it to Thor as the
Thorforce.
But the MCU never explains nor shows this,
and that leads to two all-important questions.
First, did Thor ever inherit that tremendous
power?
And if not, might instead the power have passed
to Asgard's king, Valkyrie?
In the past, the line of kings has always
been genetic as well as political, but ever
since the end of "Avengers: Endgame," when
Thor made Valkyrie king, the two lines are
separate, and so the MCU may very well have
its own Thorforce, Valkyrieforce, both, or
neither.
If there is one question that the Marvel movies
of Phase 4 have repeatedly raised, it is:
To what extent are humanity, power, and destiny
all related?
In "Spider-Man: No Way Home," we saw a human,
Dr. Strange, tear apart the fabric of the
multiverse.
In "Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness,"
we saw both Strange and another human, the
Scarlet Witch, do the same on an even larger
scale.
Then, in "Thor: Love and Thunder," we see
another human, Jane Foster, wield the weapon
of a god, become a god herself, and fight
toe-to-toe with gods — as did her antagonist,
Gorr.
And with the increasing number of uber-powerful
beings populating the MCU that are not gods,
like the Watcher and the Celestials, the question
of what exactly a god is has become more vexing
than ever.
A particularly puzzling detail about the MCU's
divine beings is that their continued existence
and power don't seem to be connected to the
one thing you would expect to be guaranteed:
worship.
When a desperate, broken Gorr comes across
his own god and explains that all of his worshippers
are dead, the god admits that he is happy
to see them go — he doesn't need them, nor
does he care about their existence.
"All gods will die"
The gods of the MCU are clearly not determined
by worship or by power — otherwise, the
reality-rewriting Scarlet Witch would be one
of their greatest.
So far, we've covered the fact that MCU's
humans are stronger than ever, both in the
growing number of super-powered beings in
their ranks and in the hyper-advanced technology
they either have or will soon have.
We've also covered the fact that the MCU's
gods seem to merely be a loose assortment
of powerful beings that aren't powerful enough
to be considered abstract entities like Eternity
or the Watcher.
The obvious question, then, is what exactly
does the cosmic hierarchy of the MCU look
like?
Two Celestials attended Zeus's meeting of
the gods, even though they aren't gods themselves.
Every god and their uncle seems aware of Eternity,
and so presumably, also its twin, Infinity.
Do universal constants and abstract beings
cohabitate freely with gods?
We know gods do with people, so that implies
a surprisingly open and tolerant universal
community.
Do the other universal constants that we haven't
met, like Galactus and the Phoenix, act in
a similarly casual manner?
And we've met two Elders of the Universe so
far — the Collector and the Grandmaster
— so are they gods, abstract beings, or
something else?
It's surprising that a universe so jam-packed
with near-omnipotent super-beings of varying
backgrounds hasn't destroyed itself yet.
One of the biggest reveals in "Thor: Love
and Thunder" is that Valhalla, the fabled
resting place for deceased Asgardian gods,
is real.
Upon her death, Foster is welcomed there by
Heimdall, who looks happy, healthy, and serene.
So if Heimdall is in Valhalla, is Odin there,
too?
What about other fallen Asgardian warriors?
And if Foster is welcome there because she
proved herself worthy and wielded Mjolnir
in defense of Asgard, then surely everyone's
favorite Mjolnir wielder, Captain America,
could end up there as well?
Perhaps more important than any of these questions
is the matter of Valhalla's accessibility.
For one thing, the very job definition of
a Valkyrie is to freely travel between Valhalla
and the other realms, so can King Valkyrie
just pop in to visit Foster and Heimdall?
Can she relay messages between them and the
living?
Can she bring them back?
Alongside Valhalla, the MCU has already confirmed
the existence of two other afterlives — the
Ancestral Plane of the Wakandan people and
the Duat of the Egyptian people.
Unless Marvel plans to make the exceedingly
bold claim that those three religions are
the only three that got it right, then in
general, we now know that afterlives exist
— and seemingly, all of them.
"The dead will drag you down into the Duat,
where you will remain forever, frozen in sand."
As we mentioned, Steve Rogers wielded Mjolnir,
so will he be given a choice between Valhalla
and a Christian Heaven?
Tony Stark saved half the sentient life in
the galaxy but died, apparently, as a non-believer.
Will he spend an eternity of punishment in
some version of Hell?
As tricky as it would be to stick the landing
on this existential conundrum, an answer from
Marvel would be a major relief when it comes
to the fate of some fan-favorite characters.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.